our other big story tonight holiday
travel week is already pretty busy out
there as you just saw 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough is at the
airport and madison how is it looking
for this sunday evening
[Music]
brian we're currently here at terminal
one baggage claim and as you can see
people are moving here at a steady pace
this past month we saw virgin atlantic
airways come through with the return of
international flights along with british
airways resume their non-stop flights
here at mccarran to and from london
recently with the eligibility expansion
of the covet 19 booster to those 18 and
older many more people feel like now is
the perfect time to travel and see loved
ones many travelers here at mccarran are
at awe at how busy the airport is right
now
it's pretty busy it's darn busy
i did not expect to see this many people
it does seem like there are people
just coming and going and it seems like
a lot especially in this airport back in
october we reported on major flight
delays from airlines such as southwest
and spirit just to name a few these
delays were happening all around the
country luckily as of now we are not
seeing any significant delays like that
at this time
you're currently looking at travelers
who just arrived and are getting their
bags and you think a lot of these
travelers are coming to visit vegas but
on the contrary as we spoke to many that
decided to celebrate their holiday early
and are now headed back home here in
vegas reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now